today we had only one objective to reach
an agreement after 17 hours of
negotiations we have finally reached it
lead us have a great in principle that
they are ready to start negotiations on
an ESM program which in other words
means continued support for Greece there
are strict conditions to be met the
favor of several national parliaments
including the Greek parliament is now
needed for negotiations on yes M program
to formally begin just isn't very happy
that the Greek proposal of 35 billion of
support to the real Greek economy has
been accepted by council the toggery
trust was a very key issue but also we
worked very hard on a lot of issues
regarding reforms the fiscal situation
depth problems financing needs etc we
were able to agree on a lot of these
issues putting in an extra effort on all
sides to get greased back on track this
compromise because it's a compromise
there are no winners and no losers I
don't think that we people has been
humiliated and I don't think that the
other Europeans were losing their face
it's a typical European arrangement so
the first couple of days attention goes
to the Greek parliament as soon as
they've done the legislation on the
first elements the national parliaments
will go to work and hopefully by the end
of the week we can take the formal
decision and give the mandate to the
institution's to draw up the deal